I I'm surprised at the amount of people
that come to my shows that are
softspoken Hispanic guys yes that are
like yeah I've been I've been uh I've
been Ling for like
years well you know what it is yeah you
know like like me and my friends we been
since like high school right because
they're they don't have a culture that's
available to them yes they do it's the
audio installation section of Best Buy
right sure but you come in and you fill
that you fill that in it's PlayStation
it's interesting because some Comics we
know it's really racial some Comics are
supported by their people yeah I'm not
supported by gay people and you're not
really supported by Puerto Ricans which
is what I like I trick them I trick them
though because Latinos you trick the
Latinos look edit this point out Latinos
are stupid okay they're easily not
editing that they're easily Tri to my
audience I will say I will not stand for
this I'm not going to sit
here this this monster spews this hate
speech know I I get when you like
Latinos and blacks like just in the wild
like in the clubs come watch our special
yeah they're on YouTube and uh but I'm
saying they they love me in the wild
they won't love if they if they they
believe the hoopla and the hype they're
not going to be into what I do but if I
just happen upon a black family in a
comedy club they're going to love what I
do now let me just rewind this if you
happen upon black family
Smith and his son Will Smith there
looking for a job black family in the
comedy club it happens they're going to
love what you do they're going to love
what I do cuz they got real problems
dude they're not going to be offended by
all these no no words dude this
guy's but by the way can we
Market your next tour like that black
families have real
problems come see Lis Gomez I'll say
this see me